الشكر موصولنا الى الامين العامه اشكرك
السيد الامين العام على كلماتك وعلى دعمك
لنا ميدانيا
وقبل ان ابدا احاطتي اود ان اغتنمها فرصه
لكي احيي النساء والرجال والاطفال
السودانيين وكذلك موظفي الامم المتحده
والعاملين الانسانيين الذين سقطوا ضحيه
القتال في السودان منذ احاطه الاخيره في
السابع عشر من ابريل نيسان تركزت جهودي
وجهود الدول الاعضاء والمنظمات الاقليميه
على تامين هدنه انسانيه او وقف لاطلاق
النار بين القوات السودانيه المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع وقد قبلت هذه الجهود بنجاح
محدود الى يومنا هذا وقد تصاعد الوضع على
الارض بشكل ماساوي من الناحيه الايجابيه
كما ذكر السيد الامين العام تم التوصل الى
وقف اطلاق النار لمده 72 ساعه
بمساع من الامم المتحده
ويبدو ان وقف النار هذا يستمر الى الان
الا ان ان
الا انه تصلنا تقارير عن اطلاق متقطع
للنار ويبدو ان القوات السودانيه المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع يا يتهمان بعضهما
البعض بانتهاك وقف اطلاق النار
في الخرطوم يستمر القتال حول القصر
الجمهوري ومطار خرطوم الدولي ومقر القوات
السودانيه المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع
والمواقع الاستراتيجيه الاخرى وفي بعض
الحالات يتكثف القتال الضربات الجويه
والقصف الكثيف يستمران كذلك لا سيما في
بحره واندرمان
قريبه من الخرطوم
كما ان مطاره الخرطوم قد عاد الى العمل
ولكن ساحه خدمه الطائره تضررت المناطق
السكنيه بالقرب من مواقع القوات السودانيه
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريعه تتعرض
للاعتداءات المنازل المتاجر المدارس
المنشات الكهربائيه والمائيه الجوامع
المستشفيات ومنشات صحيه اخرى تعرضت للضرر
او تدمرت كليا وثمت تقارير عن مصادره
المنازل ونهبها ونهب المتاجر وسرقه
السيارات عند الحواجز
وكما ان
المواطنين السودانيين وموظفين الامم
المتحده والعمال الانسانيين والدبلوماسيين
يتعرضون جميعا لهذه الاعتداءات وصلتنا
ايضا تقارير مقلقه عن اعتداءات جنسيه
وكذلك عن انقطاع طرق الامداد
بالاضافه الى التقارير عن اطلاق السراحي
المساجين من بعض مراكز الاحتجاز في خرطوم
مع صعد من هذه المخاوف في ولايه الشمال ان
السيطره على مطار مراوي
نقطه تنازع بين الطرفين ومجموعه من القوات
تم احتجازها من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
ولكن تم اطلاق سراحها مؤخرا الوضع في
درفور يبقى متقلبا في شمال دارفور وبفضل
وقف محلي لاطلاق النار بتدخل من السلوط من
السلطات الولايه ومن القيادات المحليه
وبدعم من لجنه اللجنه وقف وقف الدائم
لاطلاق النار برئاسه اليونيد تامز تراجع
العنف خلال فتره عيد الفطر
وما زال وقف اطلاق النار مستمرا الى الان
وفي غرب دارفور بالقرب من الجنينه وعلى
طول الحدود مع تشاد تم استئناف العنف
ولدينا المقلقه عن قبائل تتنحر وتنضم الى
القتال نيالا في جنوب دارفور تشهد قتالا
كذلك بالرغم من ان المبادرات المحليه التي
تهدف الى الحوار قد سمحت باحلال بعض
الهدوء في مناطق محدده في شمال قردوفان
قتالا متقطعا في العبيد وفي ولايه
الانيل الازرق في 21 من ابريل نيسان
حصلت مناوشات
وهناك مناطق اخرى
تشهد تدفقات
النازحين وبالرغم من ذلك او بسبب ذلك
تواجه هذه المناطق رقصا في الخدمات
الاساسيه وفي الفيول
ولدينا كذلك تقارير تفيد
بازدياد عمليات النهب عند
الحواجز على الطرقات وسرقه المدنيين الذين
يهربون من العنف السيد الرئيس ان القتال
في السودان قد تسبب بكارثه انسانيه يتحمل
عبئها المدنيون
صبيحه هذا اليوم 4
او حتى صبيحه هذا اليوم 427 شخصا قتلوا
اكثر من 3700 جرحوا وهذه الارقام
لا تعكس الواقع الحقيقي الوضع الانساني
كما
ستفيدكم السيده من سوريا ماساوي ولكنني لن
ادخل في تفاصيلهم الشبكات المجتمع المدني
الشبكات على الارض قد حشدت كل قدراتها
لتعبئه هذا الفراغ وتم تشكيل لجان مقاومه
محليه وهناك لجان تدعمون تنسيق اجلاء
المدنيين من المناطق المتضرره وفي وسط
العنف نرى ان المواطنين السودانيين رجالا
ونساء يقفون في تضامن وتعاطف مع بعضهم
البعض اصحاب السعاده كلا طرفي النزاع
يقاتلان مع انتهاك كامل للقوانين
لقواعد الحرب ويستهدفون المناطق المدنيه
بشكل عشوائي ولا يحترمون لا المستشفيات
ولا المنشات المدنيه ولا حتى السيارات
التي
المرضى والجرحى لذلك اناشد الطرفين احترام
موجباتهما بموجب القانون الدولي وضمان
حمايه المدنيين والبنى التحتيه المدنيه
فلابد من تامين ممر امن للمدنيين لمغادره
مناطق النزاع
ويجب ان يسمح لهم بالوصول الى الامدادات
ان امن وسلامه موظفي الامم المتحده ومواقع
الامم المتحده
واصولها والموظفين الانسانيين والطبيين
امر اخر لابد من ضمانهم وقد تابعت تواصلي
المنتظم مع الفريق برهان
حماتي عثيم على وقف القتال والسماح
بالهدنه الانسانيه
وقد تمكنا من
التفاوضي والتواصلي الى هدنه انسانيه ثلاث
مرات ولكنها لم تستمر الا لبضعه ساعه
وبمناسبه عيد الفطر وبدعم من الامين العام
تمكنا من اقناع الفريق برهان
والجنرال حماتي
بهدنه من ثلاثه ايام بدات في 21 من ابريل
نيسان وقد وفر ذلك هدله بسيطه لاسودانيين
في العاصمه وفي مختلف انحاء البلاد ومكنت
الامم المتحده وشركاء الانسانيين من نقل
موظفهم بعيدا عن خطي النار الا ان هذه
الهدنه لما تحترم بشكل كامل فاستمرت
الضربات الجويه على المقرات ومحاولات
للسيطره على مناطق اضافيه
في مقابل ذلك ان وقف المحاليل لاطلاق
النار في اجزاء من دارفور ومناطق اخرى
يستمر بالرغم من انه ليس مطلقا
تقارير عن حشد بعض القبائل
وحركات المسلحه في دارفور
يمكن ان
يكون خطيرا ولذلك اكرر دعوتي الى كل
المجموعات الى احترام الحياد وعدم دعم
فريق ضد فريق اخر اصحاب السعاده اعضاء
المجلس
كلا القائدين لم يلتزم بوقف كامل لاطلاق
النار
والفريقان يستمران في تبادل الاتهامات وفي
اطلاق مزاعم السيطره على منشات اساسيه
وحتى الان لم نرى ما يؤكد لنا ان ايا
منهما جاهز لتفاوضا جدي
ما يوحي بان هما يحاولان السيطره عسكريا
على الاخر
ونحن نعتبر ان هذا حساب خاطئ
وادي يستمر القتال
ينهار النظام والقانون في السودان وسوف
تتبدد القياده
وتزداد الشردمه في السودان ما سينعكس سلبا
على المنطقه برمتها وحتى ولو ربح احد
الطرفين فان السودان سيخسر لسوء الحظ وبما
اننا لم نتمكن من تامين هدنه مستدامه ووقف
دائمه لاطلاق النار منذ بدايه القتال فان
الامم المتحده قد اتخذت قرارا باجلاء وسحب
موظفيها من اخر الخرطوم ودرفور ومناطق
اخرى وانا اتحدث اليكم اليوم من بورتسودان
حيث العديد من زملائي وشركائنا من
المنظمات غير الحكوميه قد وصلت البارحه
1100 شخص بمن فيهم 744 من موظفي الامم
المتحده واسرهم والمنظمات الدوليه غير
الحكوميه
واسرهم والمنظفين الدبلوماسيين من عدد من
السفارات قد انتقلوا جميعا الى بورتسودان
من الخرطوم بعد
ظهر اليوم
450 منهم قد صعدوا على متن طائره التجاريه
والباقون سيتم اجلائهم في سفن تجاريه في
يومين القادمين وبعض الموظفين الدوليين
واسرهم ما زالوا في الخرطوم ولم يتم
اجلؤهم لاسباب مختلفه
سنستمر في ضمان ان موظفينا
الوطنيين قادرين على الانتقال الى مناطق
امنه والموظفين في غرب ووسط دارفور تم
اجلاؤهم
نقلهم الى مناطق اخرى
وان اجلاء الموظفين من الفاشر الشمال
دارفور لم يبدا بعد ولكننا ندرس الخيارات
مع
دعم محتمل من الدول الاعضاء واود ان اعرب
هنا عن امتنان الى الدول الاعضاء التي
تساهم في تيسير عمليات الاجلاء والانتقال
هذه ونحن نعول على تعاونها المستمر
لاستكمال عمليه الاجلاء والنقل هذه
واسمحوا لي ان اتحدث بصراحه ان عمليات
الاجلاء والنقل لا تعني بان الامم المتحده
تتخلى عن السودان
سنستمر بالتواجد في السودان
بالرغم من تقليص عددنا وسنركز على
اولوياتنا الفوريه بالتنسيق مع شركائنا
الدوليين وهذه الاولويات هي وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار مع اليه رفض عوده الى
المفاوضات السياسيه وتخفيف المعاناه
البشريه
بالنسبه الى وقف اطلاق النار تمت مبادره
اطلقتها الولايات المتحده بالتعاون الوثيق
معنا
في اطار الاليه الثلاثيه اصحاب السعاده
ان الامم المتحده
وشركائنا يضاعفون الجهود لضمان ان وقف
اطلاق النار ل72 ساعه سيستمر ويتحول الى
وقفنا دائم للاعمال العدائيه والى عوده
الى المفاوضات السياسيه
كلا
القائدين العسكريين يجب ان يلتزم بوقف
النار وان يعمل على تدعيمه وتحويله الى
وقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه بتيسير من
الاليه الامم المتحده على استعداد لدعم
ذلك واناشد الدول الاعضاء التي لديها نفوذ
على الاطراف المتناحره ان تضغط على هذه
الاطراف وان الشخصيات السودانيه بما فيها
رئيس الوزراء السابق خندوق وقيادات من قطع
الاعمال والاحزاب السياسيه والمجتمع
المدني كلها تعمل ضد الحرب وتدعو الى وقف
لاطلاق النار والى دعم انساني وانا انسق
بشكل وثيق مع كل هؤلاء اصحاب السعاده
ان الشجاعه ومقاومه اصدقائنا السودانيين
والموظفين الوطنيين والشركاء في السودان
مصدر الهام بالنسبه الينا واوصله الامم
المتحده برمتها لن نتكلم
لوقف العنف في السودان والاعاده الامل
بمستقبل افضل الامم المتحده ملتزمه
بالسودان وبشعب السودان وشكرا
اشكر السيده على احاطته واعطي الكلمه الان
الى السيدات جويس مسويه
السيد الرئيسه
شكرا
لاعطائي فرصه احاطه المجلس حول الوضع
الانساني الماساوي في السودان
واود بدايه ان اعرب عن خالص الامتنان لكل
الزملاء العاملين في المجال الانساني
ولشعب السودان نفسه اشكرهم على جهودهم
الباسله
لتعريض حياتهم للخطر لمساعده الاخرين ونحن
لن نالوا جهدا لدعمهم في هذه الاوقات
العصيله
ما يحصل هناك منذ الخامس عشر من نيسان
ابريل كابوس بالنسبه الى المواطنين
العاديين وعمال
المساعده لذلك لابد للقتال ان يتوقف
السيده الرئيسه حتى قبل الخامس عشر من
نيسان ابريل كانت الحاجات الانسانيه في
السودان تسجل مستويات غير مسبوقه 15.8
مليون شخص اي ثلث السكان كان بحاجه الى
المساعدات الانسانيه 4 ملايين طفل وامراه
حامل او مرضعه كانوا يعانون من سوء
التغذيه وثلاثه فاصل سبعه مليون شخص
تعرضوا لنزوح الداخلي
هذا النزاع لن يفاقم فقط من هذه الحاجات
ولكنه يهدد كذلك
باطلاق موجه جديده من التحديات الانسانيه
القتال يعيق عمليات المساعده ويعرضها
للخطر
وان الازمه الانسانيه تتحول بسرعه الى
كارثه اكثر من 400 وخمسين شخص قد قتلوا
واكثر من
3700 قد جرحوا عشرون مستشفى على الاقل قد
اضطر للاغلاق بسبب الاضرار التي لحقت بها
او للاستخدامها العسكري او لعدم توفر
الموارد القطاع الكهرباء وعدم توفر الوقود
يعرض للخطر اللقاحات وامدادات المياه ما
يمكن ان يفضي بدوره الى انتشار الامراض ما
وصلتنا تقارير متعدده عن عنف جنسي وجنساني
لذلك ندعو كل الاطراف الى ضمان ان النساء
والفتيات لا يتعرضن لهذه الجرائم
ان تاثير ما يجري على الصحه النفسيه
والعقليه لا سيما في صفوف الاطفال تفوق
التصور
السيد الرئيسه ان الاسره الانسانيه
كذلك بحصتها من الماسي فقد خسرنا خمسه من
من الزملاء وان عمال المساعده يتم توقيفهم
في منازلهم ويدرمون ويهددون بالسلاح كما
ان المخازن والمكاتب والمركبات قد اتعرضت
للاعتداء والنهب والمصادره الوضع خطير
للغايه ويثير قلقنا البالغ السيد الرئيس
التزامنا بشعب السودان
ما زال على حاله وبالرغم من اننا اضطررنا
لخفض تواجدنا في مناطق القتال
يجب ان يفهم الجميع باننا لن نغادر
السودان وان الفريق الانساني وقياداته
سيبقى في البلد في بورتسودان لاداره
العمليات وعندما يكون ذلك ممكنا ستستمر
العمليات الانسانيه بفضل التزامي
المساعدين الانسانيين بما في ذلك الشركاء
المحليين معا سنستمر في تقديم المساعده
اينما ومتى كان ذلك ممكنا لاسيما في مجال
الصحه والتغذيه ونحن نسعى الى سبل لاعاده
تاميني
الموارد الضروريه لايصال المساعدات الى
شركائنا في بورسودان ومناطق اخرى حال ما
يصبح ذلك امنا ونحن نشغل كذلك مركزا في
نيروبي لدعم الاستجابه السريعه كما نعد
لتدفقات اللاجئين الى دول المنطقه
لقد وصلتنا تقارير عن عشرات الاف الاشخاص
الذين يصلون الى جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
وتشاد ومصر واثيوبيا وجنوب السودان
اشكر كل هذه البلدان التي تستقبل الهاربين
من القتال من الاهميه بمكان ان نبقي
الحدود مفتوحه ونعمل كذلك على اعاده توزيع
المخصصات التي وصلتنا اخيرا من صندوق
الاستجابه الطارئه ومن الصندوق الانساني
للسودان وسنستمر بالعمل مع شركاء المحليين
وشبكات المجتمع المدني للوصول الى من
يحتاج المساعده السيده الرئيسه القانون
الانساني الدولي لا يترك مجالا للبس يتعين
على كل اطراف النزاع ان يحترموا المدنيين
والبنى التحتيه المدنيه
وان يبذلوا كل الجهود لتجنب الاضرار بها
ويشمل ذلك ضمان المرور الامن للمدنيين
لمغادره مناطق الاعتداءات بشكل طوعي
وعليها كذلك ان تحترم العاملين الانسانيين
والاصول وتيسير عمليات الاغاثه كما على
هذه الاطراف اطراف النزاع ان تحترم
الموظفين الطبيين والمنشات الطبيه السيده
الرئيسه اعضاء المجلس الموقرون ما يحتاجه
شعب السودان وما نحتاجه نحن للوصول الى
شعب السودان هو وقف فوري لاطلاق النار وحل
دائم للازمه ونعول على جهودكم الحديثه
لتحقيق هذه الغايه شكرا لحسن الاصغاء
اشكر السيده مسويه على احاطتها واعطي
الكلمه الان الى سعاده السيده فاطمه قياري
محمد
شكرا السيد الرئيسه
يشرفني ان ادلي بهذا البيان بالنيابه عن
الرئاسه مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
سعاده السيده موسى محمد فقيه الذي لم
يتمكن من الانضمام الينا اليوم
وبدايه اود ان اهنئكم على تراوس مجلس
الامن خلال شهر ابريل نيسان واشكركم لدعوه
الاتحاد الافريقي للتحدث في هذه الاوقات
الحساسه وشكرا موصول كذلك الى الامين
العام والسيده بيرتس والسيده مسيوه على
احاطاتهم وانا اتطلع الى الاستماع الى
احاطه مبعوث الايجاد السيده اسماعيل وايز
السيده الرئيسه اعضاء المجلس الموقرون
ان دوره الاتحاد الافريقي في الدعم
الاطراف السودانيين الوطنيين قد افضى فئه
اغسطس 2019 الى اتفاق انتقالي وهذا
الاتفاق قضاء استمع
باستقرار نسبيا لسنتين وشمال ذلك في العام
2020 توقيع اتفاق جوبا للسلام مع
المجموعات السودانيه المسلحه وخلال تلك
الفتره
نزعت السودان عن قائمه الولايات المتحده
لدول الراعيه للارهاب وشاهدنا عوده
السودان الى الاسره الدوليه واتخاذ قرارات
جوهريه حول الغاء الديون والمساعدات
التنمويه والاقتصاديه اثر عقود من
العقوبات او جزاءات على السودان ما سمحت
بارساء اسس سوداني مزدهر ومستقر ولكن في
اكتوبر 2021 حصل الانقلاب وادى ذلك الى
تعليق مجلس الامن والسلام تابع لاتحاد
الافريقي
لمساهمه السودان في كل انشطه الاتحاد
ونذكر بان الرئه قد سافرت الى السودان خمس
مرات منذ انقلاب تشرين اول اكتوبر للتواصل
مع الاطراف العسكريين والمدنيين والضغط
عليهم للتواصل الى اتفاق من اجل اعاده
حكومه بقياده مدنيه وانهاء مرحله
الانتقاليه بتنظيم انتخابات عامه
ومنذ
العوده الى العنف الذي بدا في الرابع عشر
من نيسان ابريل من هذا العام اصدر الاتحاد
الافريقي بيانا دعا فيه الى نزع فوري
لتفتيل التوتر والى وقف لاطلاق النار
والعوده الى طاولات المفاوضات ومن جانبه
الى مجلس السلم والامن قد عقد جلسه طارئه
للنظر في التطورات المقلقه في السودان
وخلال هذا الاجتماع طلب المجلس الاطراف
السودانيين اعتماد حل سلمي والحوار وقد
طلب كذلك الى رئاسه المجلس ان تستخدم
مساعها الاحميد للتواصل مع المتناحرين
وانطلاقا من هذه الروحيه عقد الرئيس
اجتماعا
رفيعا المستوى في العشرين من نيسان ابريل
دعي اليه امين عام الامم المتحده والايجاد
وجامعه الدول العربيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
والاعضاء الخمسه الدائمه العضويه في مجلس
الامن والدول الثلاثه الاعضاء في مجلس
الامن ودول مجاوره للسودان كما المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الامارات العربيه
المتحده قطر والنرويج والمشاركون من ضمن
امور اخرى اتفقوا على الاستنتاجات التاليه
اذان العنف ودعوا الى وقف فوري انساني
لاطلاق النار للسماحي بالاحتفال بعيد
الفطر ما يمهد لوقف اكثر دواما لاطلاق
النار
طلب كذلك المتقطلين باقامه ممرات انسانيه
والسماح بوصول من دون عقبات للي اخذ
لمساعدات الانسانيه لاستجابه للحاجات
الملحه للسكان بما في ذلك اعاده تاهيل
واستخدام البنى التحتيه الاساسيه المدنيه
والاساسيه ماء الخدمات المائيه
والكهربائيه واحترام سلامه الموظفين
الدبلوماسيين والانسانيين واعاده فتح
البنى التحتيه الخاصه بالنقل مثل مطار خرط
الخرطوم الدولي دعا المشاركون كذلك الى
استئناف فوري للعمليه السياسيه من خلال
الحوار والمفاوضات من اجل تشكيل حكومه
جامعه بقياده مدنيه رفض المشاركون كافه
اشكال التدخلات الخارجيه والتزم المشاركون
بالتنسيق والتعاوني في
عملهم المشترك وفي هذا السياق طلبوا الى
الاليه الثلاثيه بقياده رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي ان توسع لتشمل جامعه
الدول العربيه والاتحاد الاوروبي وترويكا
واطراف ثنائيين للتواصل مباشره مع قيادات
القوات السودانيه المسلحه وقوات الدعم
السريع واصحاب الشان الاخرين
ويتوقع من الاليه الموسعه ان تجتمع في
الايام القادمه لمناقشه خطوات عمليه فوريه
تتعلق
بوقف للاعمال العدائيه
مرتبط بالوصول الانساني وكلاهما يخضع
بالاولويه قبل اي اي من الخطوات الاخرى
وكل ذلك يقوم على المبادئ التوجيهيه
للاتحاد الافريقي والاسيه ما انه ما من
عمل عسكري يمكن ان يسوي هذه الازمه وان اي
عمليه سياسيه يجب ان تكون عمليه سياسيه
تقوم على ما تم الاتفاق عليه
وان اي عمليه سياسيه يجب ان تكون اذا
عمليه بملكيه سودانيه وجامعه
وقرروا كذلك رفضهم لاي تدخل
اجنبي يمكن ان يفاقم الوضع الخطير في
السودان والمنطقه والقاره الافريقيه
ويضر بملايين المدنيين الابرياء السيده
الرئيسه اود كذلك ان اذكر بان اجتماع
العشرين من ابريل نيسان قد فوض الاتحاد
الافريقي والامم المتحده بتنسيق بتنسيق
العمل الدولي حول السودان بغيه التوصل الى
انهاء فوري للعنف
وزعزعه الاستقرار في السودان والمنطقه
والقاره وتم تخاطر حقيقي بامتداد النزاع
الى المنطقه وتحوله الى انتزاع الى نزاع
دولي فكل المكونات موجوده ومهيئه وقد
شاهدنا ذلك منذ 11 عاما في ليبيا وهي على
حدود السودان الشماليه وبالتالي ان
المنطقه برمتها ما زالت تتاثر بنتائج ما
حصل منذ 11 يوما لذلك على الاسره الدوليه
ان تتحدث بصوت واحدا وبالتنسيق مع الاتحاد
الافريقي واود ان اؤكد على دور الاجابه
المهم وذلك اساسي لاعاده الاطراف
السودانيين الى الطاوله وتشجيع الحوار
السلمي في هذا السياق يتطلع الاتحاد
الافريقي الى الزياره التي سيقوم تقوم بها
بعثه الوساطه الرفيعه مستوى تابعه لايجاد
الى السودان
يعرب الاتحاد عن استعداده لتيسير هذه
الزياره التي ستمثل مساهمه مهمه للجهود
التي تبدلها الاسره الدوليه برمتها ومن
وجهه نظر اوسع يستمر الاتحاد الافريقي
بالتعبير عن بالغ قلقه ايذاء النتائج التي
يمكن ان يستتبعها الوضع الخطير الحالي على
العمليه الرئاسيه بشكل عام التي كانت قد
سجلت تقدما مهما بالرغم من الصعوبات التي
واجهتها يتعين على الاطراف السودانيين الا
ينسوا الهد الاساس من تشكيل حكومه جامعه
بقياده مدنيه يراسها رئيس الوزراء رئيس
وزراء يعينوا بالتوافق لاداره العمليه
الانتقاليه نحو الديمقراطيه في السودان
وعلينا ان نستفيد من الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
بين منظمتين اي الاتحاد الافريقي والامم
المتحده ومع الاطراف الاقلبيين لتعزيز
التنسيق حول مختلف النواحي ما يسمح بزياده
جدوى هذا الدعم وتاثيره الايجابي اخيرا
سيد الرئيس
اكرر دعوه امين عام الامم المتحده
الى كل المتقاتلين لنزع
والى الاحترام الكامل لوقف اطلاق النار
بغيه تسهيل الجهود التي تبذل وعلينا الا
ان ننسى الاكثر تضررا من دوامه النزاع هذه
اي شعب السودان ويجب ان نستمر بالانخراط
معهم
وسيتابع الاتحاد الافريقي رصدا الوضع عن
كثب وسوف يحيط المجلس باي تطور وشكرا
صاحبه السعاده فاطمه كياري محمد على هذا
البيان للاسف
ممثل الهيئه الحكوميه الدوله المعنيه
بالتنميه الايجاد لم يتمكن من الاتصال
بالانترنت لذا اقترح عليكم ان نبدا
الاستماع الى اعضاء المجلس واعطي الكلمه
الى الاعضاء الرغم نفر ادلاء ببيان اعطي
الكلمه اولا الى مندوبه المملكه المتحده
اولا شكرا
سيدتي الرئيسه في المستهل اشكر الممثل
الخاص لمين العام
المساعده
والسيده فاطمه محمد
المراقبه من الاتحاد الافريقي والسيد
اسماعيل وايس وان كان غائبا
في المستهل
احييك على جهودك
مع فريق اليوتني وكالات المتحده ومنظمه
غير الحكوميه والشركاء المنفذين في
الميدان نحن نشعر
بانفراجه بعد الاجلاء ونقل العاملين
دولينا وعملي الامم المتحده وتوجه ذلك
بالنجاح ونشكرك انت وفريقك على تفانيكم في
السودان ونتقدم بخالص التعازي الى اسر
الزملاء الذين فقدوا عزيزا بالنسبه
المملكه المتحده لقد اجرينا عمليه اجلال
لافراد السفاره في 23 من ابريل وبدانا
اليوم النقل الرعايه البريطانيه نشكر
اشركاء الدوليين عالم اعمالهم وتعاونهم في
هذه الجهود
واولوياتنا تظن سلامه جميع الرعايا
البريطانيين في السودان ودعم اولئك
المحتاجين للدعم
المملكه المتحده بشكل الناقات
العسكريه التي تقع في ارجاء السودان
ونكرر دعوه الامن من اجل السلام
وتحديدا من اجل وقف الهجمات على المدنيين
والعاملين الانسانيين
الماءات ماتوا
والالاف اصيبوا
اضافه الى اوضاع انسانيه حرجه في البلد
نرحب بوقت اطلقنا لمده 72 عاما وابرمته
الولايات المتحده ولكن نشعر بالانشغال
لانه مره اخرى الاطراف لم تتمكن من اعلاء
هذه الالتزامات
ندعو
القوات المسلحه السوداني واخوه الدعم
السريع
الى
انشاء وقفا اطلاق النار فوري في ارجاء
البلد ونحن نتواصل مع قيادتي القوتين لوقف
العنف
ونزع فتيل التوتر
ندعو الطرفين
للسماحي بنفاذ الانساني
والامتثال لالتزاماتهما بموجب قانون
الانساني الدولي وضمان حمايه المدنيين
والعاملين الانسانيين واطبين ونرحب بل
نشجع ايضا
المبادره الدبلوماسيه الاقليميه بما في
ذلك تلك التي اتت اليوم
وسنواصل العمل مع كل اعضاء المجلس والامين
العميل المتحده لضمان
مواصلات هذه الجود من الامم المتحده
والمجلس نحو وقف اطلاق النار ونحو تسويه
دائمه للاوضاع وفي الختام نحن متضامنون مع
الشعب السوداني في مطالباتهم
بمستقبلا ينعم بالسلام والازدهار شكرا
اشكر مندوبه المملكه المتحده على هذا
البيان اعطي الكلمه الان الى ممثله
الولايات المتحده تفضلي
شكرا يا سيدتي الرئيسه
اشكر الامين العام جوترش والممثل الخاص
بارتس والامين العام المساعده مشويه
الخاصه مبعوث الخاصه على الاحاطات المقدمه
الثاقبه وشكرا على جهودكم على وجه التحديد
في نهايه الاسبوع السعي لانهائي القتالي
واراقه الدماء اشكر ايضا ارحب ايضا
بمشاركتي المراقبه دائما الاتحاد الافريقي
والمبعوث الخاص للايجاد
من نافله القول ان نشعر بخابه الامل لان
المجلس لم ينعقد في وقت مبكر حول هذا
الوضع لان الوضع في السودان يستوجب
وعناياتنا وشعب السوداني يستحق عنايتنا
وكان لابد من الانقاذ لتلبيه الاحتياجات
الانسانيه
وايضا لابد من العمل مع القوات القوتين
لان رساله واضحه المعارك يجب ان تتوقف
فورا وكما قال الامين العام للتو الاختتال
يجب ان يتوقف هو الاخر
الولايات المتحده تدين باشد العبارات
بتواصل العنف بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريعه
وندعوهما الى الالتزام بالواجبات وتنفيذي
واعلاء وقفل اطلاق النار لمده 72 ساعه بدا
في منتصف
يوم رابع والعشرين من هذا الشهر ندعو جميع
الاطراف النزاع للعمل مع الشركاء الدوله
واصحاب المصلحه السودانيين المحليين معا
يجب ان يشكلوا لجنه لمراقبه المفاوضات
والاستنتاجات والتنفيذ
لوقف العدوان بشكل دائم
وللترتيبات الانسانيه في السودان
والودن المتحده تدعم وبقوه
مواصلات الجهود الدبلوماسيه من الاتحاد
الافريقيه
والايجاد
وجمعه الدول العربيه
واليونيتامس لتسويه هذه الازمه كما اننا
نرحب
ببيان العشرين من ابريل حول الدوره
الوزاريه الخاصه في ذلك المتحده والايجاز
وجمعه الدول العربيه وبلدان الجوار
والاعضاء الدائمين الخمسه في مجلس الامن
ليست هذه رسائل منفصله بل هذه هي الاسره
الدوليه التي تتحدث بصوت قوي واحد ولقد
حان الوقت للقاده العسكريين في السودان ان
يستمعوا الى دعوتنا الجمعيه ومنذ اسبوع
وهذا ما قيل قبل ذلك العنف بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع قد
قتل اكثر من 420 مدنيا
واصاب الالاف
وضع حياه السودانيين في خطر
وهدد العاملين الانسانيين
ودفع الملايين المغادره ديارهم كما نشعر
بالانشغال بسبب اللغات عن العنف الجنسي
والانتهاكات الجنسيه وغير ذلك من صور
العنف وقوات الدعم السريع يجب ان تحترم
القانون الدولي وعليها ايضا وفورا ان
تلتزم بالسلامه والامن والحمايه للمدنيين
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه والافراد وموظفين
المتحده
والافراد الانسانيين وطبييين ومقال ممتحنه
بما في ذلك ضمان العوده الامنه والسليمه
للافراد الدبلوماسيه الاجانب كما نشعر
بالانشغال الشديد بسبب الاحتياجات
الانسانيه في الاوضاع الانسانيه الحرجه
ووفقا للاوتش الاحتياجات الانسانيه في
السودان كانت قد بلغت مساواه قياسيه قبل
اندلاع العنف الاخير والهجمات على موظفي
المساعده الانسانيه والمعدات والمكاتب
والمستودعات قاد اوقف العمليات الانسانيه
والمدنيون سينفذ طعامهم ووقودهم وغير ذلك
من الامدادات الاساسيه والطبيه الحرجه
لهذا السبب لابد مان
النفاذ الانساني الفوري والكامل والامن
ودون عراقيل ودائم اضافه الى مئات
المدنيين المصابين فان ثلاثه من المساعدين
الانسانيه قد قتلوا اضافه الى افرادا
دوليين ونحن نقدم تعزي الى اسرهم وزملائهم
وتعليق انشطه
الاغذيه صندوق الاغذيه العالميه سيؤثر في
البلد ولكن لم يكن امام الامم المتحده
خيار
البعثه الامريكيه قد تعرضت للهجمه
وسفارتنا تعرض للهجمات المباشره وغير
مباشره وهذه الهجمات جبانه
وغير مقبوله
وندعو دائما ندعو قوات الامن الى حمايه
الافراد الدبلوماسيين والمدنيين والافراد
اللسانينه والبنا التحتيه الانسانيه بما
يتماشى مع التزامات السودان
بموجب اتفاقيه فيينا حول الامتيازات
الدبلوماسيه واخيرا اود ان اكرر التالي
لا بد من المسائله بما في ذلك الافراد
العسكريين او السياسيين الذين يحاولون
تقويد عمليه التقدم الديمقراطيه في
السودان وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لاي شخص
مسؤول عن انتهاك القانون الانساني الدولي
وانتهاكات والانتهاكات والاعتداءات في
حقوق الانسان والولايات المتحده تتضمن مع
شعب السودان
ونحن نتضمن مع العاملين الانسانيين الذين
يواصلون الساعه لتقديم المساعده
كما قلنا مرارا وتكرارا الى القوات
المسلحه السودانيه لقد حان الوقت
للحوار بدلا من حمل السلاح شكرا
اشكر ممثله الولايات المتحده على هذا
البيان اعطي الكلمه الان الى الصين
شكرا يا سيدتي الرئيس سيدتي رئيسه اولا
اود ان اشكر الامين العامج
على احاطته في بدايه هذا الاجتماع ايضا
كما اشكر السيد
السيد
محمد
والسيده موسيه والسيد برتس
ان اندلاع النزاع المسلح في السودان مؤخرا
قد ادى الى خسائر كبيره في صفوف المدنيين
وخسائر في البناء التحتيه في السودان ونحن
صديق للسودان
ويؤسفنا ما يحدث في السودان وندعو لطرفين
في النزاع الى الاولويه لمصالح البلد
والشعب ووقفي العدوان وبسرعه لتفادي
المزيد من التصعدي
كما اننا لحظنا ان طرفين في النزاع قد
التزم
بوقفا لاطلاق
لمده 72 ساعه ونعما ان هذا الوقت سينفذ
بشكل تام وذلك وايضا سيتم تامين البعثه
الدبلوماسيه في البلد
وسيتم تقديم الدعم عبر المساعده الانسانيه
وسيتم اجراء الافراد
وسيتم نقل بعض الافراد واشكر كل الاطراف
على مساعدتهم وتيسيرهم للاجلاء ولنقل
الرعايه الصينيين والصينوا
العربيه والاتحاد الافريقيه والايجاد
والمنظمات الاقليميه الاخرى وبلدان
المنطقه على دور حيوان الرد على هذا هذه
الاوضاعف السودان ونرحب
بالاجتماع في العشرين من ابريل وهو شمال
طائر الاتحاد الافريقي
والايجاد طلبت من جيبوتي وبلد اخر ان
يزور البلد في اقرب الاجيال عندما تسمح
الاوضاع الامنيه بذلك
كما اننا ننوه بجهودي الامين العام الامين
العام وفريق الامم المتحده وندعم الامم
المتحده في مواصله تنسيق الجهود مع
الاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد
والمنظمه الاقليميه الاخرى لتحقيق اوجه
التظافر
وفي الخامس عشر من ابريل صدر بيان يواجه
رساله واضحه تدعو الى وفاه اطلاق النار
وتعزز محادثات السلام والمجلس ان النظر في
الخطوات التاليه يجب ان تماما الى اراء
الاعضاء الافارقه ويجب ان يحترمها
والمنظمات الاقليميه من ذلك الاتحاد
الافريقي
سيدتي الرئيسه
السودان بلد هام في القرن الافريقي
ان نتصعد وطال امده فهذا سيعني
زياده المخاطر وهذا لا يصب في صالح
السودان
وسيضر بسلم الامن دوليين
لابد من وقف العدوان فورا ولابد من حث
الطرفين في النزاع على تشويات الاختلافات
عبر الحوار
واعاده العمليه السياسيه الى المسار
الصحيح ايضا اضافه الى النظام الاجتماعي
يجب فيجب ان يعود الى مسار الصحيح فشعب
السوداني يجب ان يحصل على افضل من ذلك ولو
احترامي الملكيه والسياده السودانيه ولابد
من مساعده السودان في النظر في الترتيبات
المؤسسيه وفقا للظروفي الوطنيه بما في ذلك
الحل الوطني غير مقبوله ولن تاتي بالنتائج
ان بيان العشري من ابريل بعد
اجتمع الاتحاد الافريقي يؤكد على رفض
السودان لاي تدخل خارجي في شؤون داخليه
للسودان الاسره الدوليه جابوا انت استمع
الى صوت السودان وبلدان المنطقه وفي
الختام اكرر
دعم الصين للسياده السودان وسلامه السودان
الاقليميه ولابد من وقف اعمال العدوان
والنزاع في السودان والعوده الى مسار
السلام والتنميه
المجتمعيه شكرا جزيلا اشكر ممثله الصين
على هذا البيان اعطي الكلمه الان الى
فرنسا تفضلوا شكرا يا سيدتي الرئيسه اشكر
الامين العام والممثله الخاص بولكربرتس
وممثل الاتحاد الافريقي
والايجاد والاوتشا على الاحاطات المقدمه
سيشدد على نقاط خمسه اولا الاوضاع في
الميدان وهي اوضاع ماساويه والمعارك قد
اسفرت على 450 قتيلا و4000
مصابه منذ 15 من ابريل ولكن الوضع اسوا في
الحقيقه وندينه
ندين العنف العشوائي والمدينه والافراد
الانسانيه والمستشفيات وافراد المتحده لا
يجب ان يستهدفوا ولابد من وقف نهب
مستودعات مستعده انسانيه ولابد من مسائله
المسؤولين عن هذه الانتهاكات ونظرا
للحالات الطارئه لقد اجلين الافراد
الفرنسيين وافراسا وعشرين بلدا اخر ونشكر
الشرطات جيبوتي على المساعده عشان نواصل
العمل مع الامم المتحده لمواصله عمليه
الاجلاء
الاولويه اليوم هي احترام وقف اطلاق النار
الانسانيه الذي يقبله الطرفان ووقف
المعارك امر ضروري كي يتمكن المدنيون من
ايجاد الملاذ الامن والرد على حالات
الطوارئ وايضا
انشاء ما مرات سنه وفرنسا بالاتحاد
الاوروبي لم تتوقف عن الرضيعات الاحتياجات
الانسانيه للسكان السودانيين
والمساعده من الاتحاد الاوروبي بلغت 600
مليون يورو منذ 2013
وانتقلتنا 44 مليون الى 73 مليون يورو
وسنواصل المشاركه في هذه المساهمات هذا
الوقف اطلاق النار الفوريه يجب ان يتعزز
نحن مستعدون لمواصله هذه الجهد مع الاطراف
الاقلاميه ومع مجمل الاطراف الدوليه الامم
المتحده واعمال المجلس تستكمل جهود
الاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد وجمعه الدول
العربيه والاعمال الجماعيه والمنسقه
ضروريهن نظرا للمخاطر التي تعدق بوحده
البلد وايضا باستقرار المنطقه ككل
هذه
الازمات تهدد الامل العراض التي حملتها
ثوره 2019 نرى انتكاسه هائله في عمليه
السلام والانتقال نحكومه مدنيه وفرنسا
تشعر بالانشغال بسبب زياده العنف على
المستوى الوطني وتعبئه مجموعه المسلحه
وفقا للانتهامات المجتمعيه
وندعو مجمل القوات السياسيه السودانيه
للامتناع عن المشاركه في هذه المعركه هنا
ندد باي محاولات لزياده عدم الاستقرار
سواء كانت بمبادره من قوات النظام القديم
او من الاطراف الخارجيه والاسره الدوليه
لن تدعم اي امر واقع ياتي بسبب حمل السلاح
وفرنسا تعرب عن تضامنها مع الشعب السوداني
وهنا احيي شجاعه المجتمع المدني السوداني
وانني لا يفوتني ذكر منعهم عالقونا في ظل
المعارك التي تتواصل ولكن يساعدنا بعضهم
البعض وكذلك ارحب بجهود الوساطه من
الجمعيات الاطراف السياسيه والسلطات
المحليه فقد حان الوقت لجميع القوات
السياسيه للعمل في ظل عمليه سلميه ودمجه
لصالح مجمع السودانيين ومن المهم لهذه
المجلس ان يعمل ان يقدم دعمه لمبادره
الاتحاد الافريقي والمنطقه شكرا جزيلا
اشكر ممثله فرنسا على هذا البين اعطي
الكلمه الان الى العربيه المتحده تفضلوا
الافراد الدوله ودبلوماسيين دعونا لا ننسى
من يبقون وسلامه المدنيه السودانيين
اولويه قصوى بالنسبه لبلدي ونحن ان ننعى
وفاه 400 شخص بسبب النزاع وبسبب غياب
البيانات في الميدان هذه الاعداد يمكن ان
تكون اعلى بكثير كما قال في حطته
من المهم جدا الان ان تتوقف عمل العدوان
ولابد مع احترام وقفه اطلاق النار لمده 72
عاما وقد بدا هذا الوقت في منتصف الليله
الماضيه وهذه الجهود ستسمح بالمساعده
الانسانيه ولكن نحتاج ايضا الى الضمانات
للتنفيذ الكامل من قبل جميع القوى في
الميدان
ويظل ذلك وفقا لمعلومات يظل ذلك من
التحديات الميدان
ونثني على تفاني القاده الاقليميين لنزع
الفتيل الازمه والحفاظ على الزخم والبنات
مالت عهد الفرقه والايجاد وجمعت الدول
العربيه دعت وبقوه وحسما الى وقف اطلاق
النار
والاطراف الاقليميون والدولان يعملون معا
لدعم السودان وهنا يجب ان نركز جميعنا على
منع اي
اي تبعتا للازمه في السودان في بلدان
الجوار ولابد من تعزيز هذه الجهود
الاساسيه
وان اصبح هذا النزاع اقليميا سيزيد ذلك
الطين بالله ومقدم الاحاطات اليوم قد
سلطوا الضوء ايضا على الاوضاع الحرجه التي
يعيش فيها ملايين السودانيين الخرطوم تحت
النيران والحياه اصبحت غير مستدامه هناك
يفتقر السكان الى الغذاء والماء ولا
الكهرباء
والاتصال والناس يفرون الى الملاذ الامن
والمعارك تتواصل بلا هوادا مما يؤدي الى
النزوع هذه الازمه قد عرقلت العمليات
لتقديم المعونه التي تخدم عشره ملايين
سوداني تقريبا وتمنع الوكالات من الرد على
احتياجاتي المشاهدين
وثلث المرافق الطبيه في السودان لم تعد
تعمل والاخرى الا كان تحت النيران او نهبت
وهذا يؤكد على ان
الاطباء السودانيين يواجهون هذه الاوضاع
الحرجه وانني احيي هذه الجهود الجيده
والباسله منهم لانقاذ الارواح ولابد من
حمايتهم عندما
يقدمون هذه الانشطه الحرجه كما اننا بنشغل
الشديد اليوم بسبب البلاغات عن عدم تمكن
الفنيين من الحصول او الوصول الى مختبر
الوطني لصحه العامه وتامين المواد
البيولوجيه الخطيره وندعو جميع الاطراف
الى السماح بالنفاذ دون دون عراقيل لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه وموظفي الصحه العامه
المحليين الى هذا المختمر لتامين المواد
والعاملون
لتقديم المساعده والموظفون الدبلوموس في
خطر
والعملون السودانيون لتقديم المعونه ايضا
معرضون للخطر وفي اخر 24 ساعه
قتل موظف في السفاره المصريه في الخرطوم
ونحن نتقدموا بخالص التعازي الى شعب مصر
الشقيق بعد هذه الخساره الفادحه
سيزيد من المعاناه المبرحه وسيزيد من عدد
الخسائر ما مانع ما من انتصار عسكري هنا
والمدنيون السودان هم الذين سيدفعون اثمن
باهظا لدى جميع الاطر
الاقليميون والوطن الدوليا يجب ان يوحدوا
الجهود يظل صامدين في دعوه من اجل وقف دعم
اطلاق النار لوقف هذه الازمه وندع موجود
الامين العام في هذا الصدد وسنواصل العمل
عملا لوقف النزاع شكرا يا سيدتي الرئيسه
اشكروا ممثله الامارات العربيه المتحده
على هذا البيان واعطي الكلمه الان الى
اليابان تفضل
شهدت الرئيس اشكر الامين العام
والامم المتحده على عمل الدؤوف الميدان
كما اشكر الممثل خاص الامينيا العام بيرتز
والامن العام المساعده
والمراقبه دائما
المتحده على الاحاطات واتقدم بخالص
التعازي الى الاسر المكلومه واتمنى الشفاء
العاجل للمصابين اود ان اتقدم من نقاط
اربع اولا حمايه المدنيين نحيط علما بان
القوات المسلحه السودانيه اوقات الدعم
السريع
احترمت او عقدته وقف انسانيه لاطلاق النار
لمده ثلاثه ايام اثناء العيد وامان
وامانتا المرور الامن وعوده امن يتم
اجلائهم الا ان المدنيات تم مهاجمتهم وعدم
كبير من المدنيين بما في ذلك النساء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات